right so again like it's not it's not
fun but it's just like how the world is
like there are double standards for men
and for women we're different we don't
operate the same way and like guys are
repulsed by girls that have slept around
women sleep with who they want men sleep
with who let them
yes point of view sucks
[Music]
so question for the guys how many bodies
is too many bodies
let's put a number to it depends on the
age
okay let's say so the average age the
average age of first marriage in the uk
is 31. okay what would you how many
bodies is too many bodies for a 31 year
old jeez hey i'm glad you're first um
over double figures over double so 10 10
10 10 and up okay
20 i'll give a little yeah
now we've got release 2022 nice brother
you're being nice you you wouldn't want
to hear 20 and yeah i agree with 20. i
think 20. so you would never lose you
would marry a woman with 20 bodies
would i marry a woman with 20 buddies
no
would you okay okay okay okay okay that
was too much what's the minimum
okay would you let me just ask the
question a different way would you marry
a girl with 10 bodies yes or no yes
would you marry 10 yeah yeah
yeah what about you okay would you marry
a girl with 15 bodies yes or no
potentially potentially yeah yeah
i think 15 is the max for me okay 20. no
no it's getting sticky
yeah
okay yes yes okay so
20 no no it's 15 is a match 15 is the
max
okay now what percent of women that are
31 do you think have less than 15 bodies
about five percent
about twenty percent twenty percent what
do you know i'm gonna ask the women this
too
go ahead twenty five percent twenty five
percent what do you what percent of
women that are thirty one have less than
fifteen bodies have less than yeah
uh just about yeah also say your name
your agent where you're from
i'll say about 50. i'm christina from
hackney i'm 35. okay
welcome to the show
i don't know
wait come back to me it's okay what
percent of women do you think have less
than 15 bodies at 31
10
10 i say fifty fifty i don't even i'm
just totally shocked when you think
sixteen is a legal age you're
everybody's thinking that forty fourteen
and you're thinking fifteen that's like
that's that's more than one a year
mhm
wow so what do you
is that or you're shy like that's a
ladder a little that's a lot yeah in
like 14 years 15
yeah
wow and that's like going that's what's
going on now
yeah yeah that's mostly one that's not
relationship that's just like shagging
didn't it well that's that's because
modern women are side checks because
because again it's a it's a
no no because remember it's a smaller
and smaller percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls so if you
look at dating app data like women only
swipe right like five percent of the
time up to you know ten fifteen percent
and that's high so women are and the
number one people way that people meet
is online dating
and so women are side chicks because
they're all sleeping with the same guys
because if you want a guy that's over
six foot that's 15 percent of men
you waving well i am
he's single if you want to be if you
want to be one of the girls
and so um
yeah so like modern women are side
chicks because that's disgusting it's a
small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls
one out of three men under 30 or either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year
so like so that indicates the trend
which is less and less and less and like
the big frustration that i hear from men
is basically that girls get ran through
by like the guys they actually want in
their 20s and then they hit like 30 and
then they're like please take me and
then they finally come around to the
like guys in their friend zone basically
at like 30.
sounds about right is that something
you've seen too the oldest one here
would you say that's a valid complaint
yeah i mean when they get older they
always try and look back at what they
could have had
but by then it's too late because
they've got loads of kids behind them
and
weird baby fathers and
i mean weird habits and
i'm just shocked about the 15. the 15.
what did you think
okay okay at 30. how many how many what
do you think most women had from your
generation
i think you just slept with the same
person for a couple of years
but
so you would have said like five by the
end of thirty but fifty yeah because the
thing is like the girls are sleeping
with that small percentage of guys right
so those guys aren't going to stick with
a girl for a couple of years because so
but the girls but because the thing is
like guys will sleep with anything so a
guy that's an eight nine or ten will
sleep with a four five or six even if
he's never seen it been seen in public
with her ever
there so having sex close your legs
don't do it it's not good
and so and so it's like uh
that is disgusting
i'm thinking
15 partners in 14 years
yeah
do you think that's a lot
that's not a lot in today's generation
it's not a lot it's a i will say it's a
different time yeah it's a different
time yeah one a year no no no no we
ain't doing that no more i'll take back
my hot girl decade because that was
nothing because i could have had like
them 15 men in the whole decade let
alone
oh yeah it's more like like you know how
you guys slept together for a couple
years it's like a couple of months
nowadays
men need to be preserving this verb and
this this
well why would they when when they have
like that small percentage of men if
they have women on a silver platter why
would they have pride in who they joke
why
because
listen you you wanna if you're gonna go
there and sleep with a girl make sure
you're like number three number four you
only be number nine number ten number 11
number 12 number 15.
because then you're you're 15.
imagine if you're number 15 honestly
honestly and you heard and you heard the
panel right the majority of my 31 have
probably slept with more
that's the question they were saying the
other day that women when the girl said
oh we can lie about it
if you're 15 by the end of by the age of
course you're going to want to lie she
was like oh what if they don't know
about the body count what if you lie
about it my guys know
oh my god do you think a man should feel
shame if he knows he's the 15th guy to
have had sex with
yeah you don't know who's been there
before you vomit in that no man can i
try and put it into retrospect and
essentially if a guy's the 15th guy here
he's going in knowing
i'm not staying
i'm leaving
straight after so
whoever's number 16 whoever's number 17
it is what it is yeah and then it will
get to someone who's like number 30 and
they're like
i'll wife it
and it's like that person is the one
that lost and everyone else got it for
well
i will say something on the other end
though a lot of guys do cap because
they'll come on these shows and they'll
say they wouldn't wipe a girl over a
certain account
and i know who they're dating
and i'm like
i'm not
i'm just kidding
i've definitely liked girls who have had
high body counts i have but how did you
know they had heart did you ask them
well they
they happen to be honest with me and i
take their word for it because it's not
a number that you would just openly want
to say
but
you know
it's always in my mind as much as i like
what'd they say what number
i just don't know what number it was a
ballpark figure
right
how do you lose cow yeah it was a
ballpark figure so then so add add 20 on
to whatever she's saying
it was a ballpark figure of close to
three figures oh
shut up
wait sorry
you got
yeah
because wow
she's taking the chance he's having a
hot girl so much
oh yeah
decades for a whole decade crazy hot
girl that's like a that's